Hello, welcome. It is June 11th, 2026.
We're in Model Stream 8.1 with Maran
Bazarani who will be presenting on
online generalized predictive coding
online. So, thank you. Take it away.
>> Hello, Daniel. Uh thanks a lot for the
opportunity. It's always a pleasure to
present at the brilliant active
immigrants institute. Um so today I'm
just going to present uh online
generalized coding which is a project
that we have been working on for the
past nearly two years. Um this is a
collaboration with my dear colleague Dr.
Simon Orbas from Manu University in
Ireland. Uh without whose uh
contribution in statistical insight this
work simply would not have been
possible.
Um, and also I've had the pleasure of
working with the most amazing panel of
supervisors, Professor Adil Resi,
Professor Brandon Murphy, and Professor
Carl Fristen on this project. So, I'm
really excited to talk to you guys about
online generalized predictive coding.
Okay, so first let's just talk about
some basics.
Um the notion of Beijian brain
hypothesis. Um so the idea is that the
brain is in the game of inferring the
hidden causes behind its own sensations.
Mathematically it can be defined as a
conditional probability distribution. Uh
that is the probability of some hidden
state X given the current sensation that
I'm experiencing.
Um that that can be formulated as a kind
of inference that hence the Beijian
brain hypothesis. there's a sort of
patient inference um game going on under
the hood and this requires having a
generative model of the world meaning uh
the brain needs to have a mechanism to
be able to model how the world out there
is changing and how those changes and
those dynamics would cause the
sensations the Y letter that you see
there the sensations that it's receiving
from the world Um so this is called
perception as unconscious inference.
It's a term that was coined by Helm
Holtz for the first time.
So the notion of a generative process
and a generative model it's uh crucial
that we get this um on the right hand
side you have the generative model. This
can be likened to our brain. It has some
hidden states on the right hand side.
Maybe I can just click on the laser
pointer here.
Cool. So it has some hidden states
internal hidden states X this can denote
the synaptic weights the neural activity
the neural modulation all of that uh can
be encoded in these internal hidden
states and there is some generative
process out there beyond our skull let's
say um that is basically the world out
there and it has some hidden states we
call them external hidden states XAR and
the idea is that the generative process
is responsible for all the sensations
that the brain is receiving.
Um so if you think about the this face
this being the actual um state of the
world out there what we receive is a
transformed noisy version of the truth
which is why here's a shadowy sort of
version transformed version of the
truth. And the idea is that the brain um
well the world causes this sensation and
the brain tries to make predictions
about that sensation based on the
internal dynamics of itself. Right? In
other words, it says if such and such
was the state of the world out there,
what would be the sensation that that I
would expect to receive? And based on
the error that it's made in that
prediction, it would keep updating its
internal states so that it can be get
better and better for future
predictions. So the key thing to get
away from this is that the generative
process is not repeat is not directly
observable by the generative model and
it resides beyond the skull. So this
boundary that the two entities share is
referred to as a markoff blanket. And
the idea is that all that the generative
model needs to know about the invisible
world out there is summarized in the
sensations that are impressed on this
blanket.
And from information theoretic
perspective, uh it is interesting to
note that these internal states over
here, um these internal hidden states
begin to carry information about the
invisible external states out there. In
other words, if you look at the nervous
system of an of an alien, you should be
able to say something about the world
that it had been living in because
because the internal states become a
reflection of the world out there and
the generative model sinks into some
sort of a synchrony with the world uh
with the world in which it lives. So
this is just very very interesting.
Um
now we've talked about the generative
model and it's time to get a little more
concrete as to what what we mean by the
generative model. Um it has two
components. The first component is a um
is uh basically a um
we call them the state dynamics equation
and the idea is that in a dynamic world
a generative model has a belief about
the dynamics of that world meaning where
the world is how fast it's moving and
what direction it's moving for example
and basically if the world is at a given
state based on the inference of the
generative model what would this dynamic
dynamics look like for example what what
would it what's velocity look like
acceleration jerk all these temporal
derivatives what would those look like
so the generative model is inferring all
of these at the same time so as you can
imagine this is a very difficult problem
because it it all happens online meaning
that once some data point has been
sampled from the world um that's all the
time the brain has to infer all these
dynamics out there in the world. Um and
then the next data point comes in. So it
is completely online and the world keeps
changing and the generative model now is
a g in in the game of chasing a moving
target online.
Um the second component is that a
generative model has a belief about how
the world and its dynamics causes its
sensations. Right? So if the world is at
state X, what is the most likely
sensation Y that I will be experiencing?
In this context, I is the generative
mode. Um
so mathematically you can define it like
this. So two two equations. The first
one X dot= f ofx new and theta plus
omega x. That's what we call a state
dynamics equation. Um that basically
says that the generative model believes
that the dynamics x dot which is the
temporal derivative of the state x which
is the velocity of x. The the generative
model believes that the dynamics of the
world can be broken down into two
components. One is a deterministic
component and the other is a stochcastic
component. F the deterministic component
we call them call it the flow. is
parameterized by some thetas and some
news and the x is the state. So this
equation maps from X to X dot right. And
the second equation we call we call it
uh the observation model that is uh
basically saying that the generative
model believes the sensations Y that are
being received again can be explained
and broken down into a deterministic
component G function and an a sort of a
stocastic component called omega Y. So
these two equations together um endow
the ability of tracking the dynamics as
well as predicting the sensations caused
by those dynamics would endow these uh
the generative model with these features
basically.
So whenever I say a generative model I
mean these two equations are together um
uh basically uh what what I mean is
basically these two equations together.
Now let's get a little deeper.
Those random fluctuations like like
there there are different ways that you
can describe them. But if you assume
that there are smooth gausian processes
all of a sudden the two equations
become probabilistic in nature.
So for example, if you think about the
first equation,
the the omega being a sort of smooth
Gaussian process with mean zero and some
precision matrix pix. If you sum these
together, it means now your dynamics
which is x dot which is the same as dx
over dt can be looked at as a variable
that is distributed normally with some
mean f which is the flow and then the
precision matrix x. Same story goes with
y. the the move that we've made here uh
is that now the brain or our generative
model has the ability to talk about
things with a degree of uncertainty. It
says this is what I believe about the
dynamics and this is how uncertain I am.
That uncertainty is encoded in these
random fluctuations omega x and omega y
um encoded by these precision matrices
um pi x and pi y. And uh in practice
what we do is we parameterize these
matrices um with some hyperparameters uh
let's call it lambda and that's those
lambdas are some are basically some of
the variables and some of the um uh yeah
some of the variables that the model has
to infer and estimate but we'll get to
that later.
Now the there is another concept that I
need to talk about uh because again this
is one of the core components of online
generalized predictive coding as a
generalized component comes from the
generalized coordinates of motion and
the idea is that okay in my generative
model I've had the ability to encode the
velocity
um my my inference about the velocity of
the world in an equation in the state
dynamics equation but nothing stops me
from taking it a few steps further and
say okay uh why not also have an
equation for the acceleration which is a
higher temporal derivative. Why not
having an equation for the jerk which is
again the higher temporal derivative? In
other words, nothing stops us from
taking those two equations and then
literally um sequentially just you know
keep taking temporal derivatives of of
those equations and expanding the
generative model in time dimension.
Now nothing would stop stop us from uh
from doing that and that is how the
generalized coordinates of motion come
into play. So now
previously our hidden state was x but
now here we we deal with x tilda this is
this tilda is the uh basically uh the
generalized aspect of this notation. Um
and if you look at what what we're
looking at here, tilda X tilda encodes
the position and all of the temp higher
temporal derivatives of X and Y tilda
similarly again the observations and
their higher temporal derivatives.
Um so when I say the brain has to infer
the world out there now the game is to
infer the entire exta right the position
velocity acceleration all of that given
the observations or basically the
generalized observations that it
receives.
Now mathematically this is how it looks
like. So if you grab the state dynamics
equation uh from the previous slide and
literally begin to take the second the
third and more temporal derivatives. So
x dot becomes x dot x dot becomes x
triple dot and you keep taking the
temple derivatives. This is what
happens. Um I mean I'm I'm happy to
discuss the details of this during the
Q&A but suffice it to say for now that
if you assume that the Jacobian is
constant in time then um and basically a
very short period of time then uh higher
temporal derivatives become like very
very easy to uh to actually do. Um so
basically uh you would end up with these
equations. Um and then uh you can do the
same with the observation model taking
the temporal derivatives uh down and
down. And the beauty the beauty of the
constant Jacobian is that um the this
Jacobian term keeps repeating it um over
and over and then you you just end up
with the x dox sort of estimations on
the right hand side and the important
thing is the actual temporal derives of
these smooth gausian processes
which under the hood has this sort of
correlation matrix. We call them the
smoothness sort of matrix that you have
to also uh deal with that determines the
correlation between noise processes at
different orders of motion. Um which
basically controls how smooth the
generative model believes that these
random fluctuations and the states and
the observations are. So by controlling
that smoothness you are equipping the
model with a prior on on this level of
smoothness on the state dynamics and on
the observations basically. So you can
summarize both these columns in s in in
two simple equations.
The one on the left as you see it's very
very similar to the state dynamics
equation except now we have all these
tilda not notations and this d this
derivative operator d
might seem a little confusing but it's
actually quite simple uh this simply
says that whatever order of motion x is
after you apply the oper the the
derivative operator d you're dealing
with a one step higher temporal
derivative what What this means is if
you're dealing with x dot here on the
left hand side you're dealing with x dot
if you're dealing with x dot here on the
left hand side you're dealing with the x
triple dot derivative and so on. So this
is just nothing fancy. This is just a
sort of mathematical sort of um trick
uh to basically make the notation more
smooth and basically more concise to be
able to have all of these equations in
just one equation wrapped up together.
And you notice that the thetas don't
have any tildas because the assumption
is that these parameters are are not
don't have any dynamics.
And same story goes with the right hand
side. So uh and again because of the
gausian smooth gausian assumption um on
the on these random fluctuations again
these equations become probabilistic
except we have these tilda notation
everywhere right so so from now on
anytime in in the context context of
online generalized coding anytime I talk
about the generative model I am talking
about these two equations equations and
generalized coordin coordinates of
motion. Right?
Now variational free energy the the
beautiful objective function that we
were trying to minimize. Um so what is
the goal here?
The goal is unline a posterior
estimation of all unknowns within the
generative model exterildas the thetas
and the precision hyperparameters
lambdas. So the x tildas uh as I said
these are hidden states thetas are
nondamic model parameters and lambdas
are just precision hyperparameters that
encode the stochasticity and the state
dynamics and the observation model
equations. Um so you can look at the
sort of um the joint probability
distribution between all these three
encoded in this letter s
and the generalized observations um as
the joint looks like this. You could
just break it down. This is just simple
breaking down into our model and some
prior over the parameters and
hyperparameters.
Um now the goal is of course I mean the
the joint is not our goal. Our goal is
to extract the exact posterior.
Remember the goal is to model human
perception using online generalized
predictive coding. And in perception and
as a as unconscious inference um we are
doing Beijian inference meaning this we
want to basically estimate some
posterior belief about the world out
there and that exact posterior is what
we want. But unfortunately as we know
from uh you know statistics this exact
posterior is intractable to calculate.
So we uh resort to the variational
calculus to come up with this sort of
surrogate posterior Q that's an
estimation of the exact posterior
um which tells us uh the posterior mean
and variance of each one of the
components inside SI. Right? So the idea
is if I can estimate a good Q then by
proxy I will have estimated the exact
posterior but estimated it then that
means I've done as good of a decent
inference about the world as I possibly
could.
So variational free energy is a
functional because it's a function of a
function.
um it's a functional of the Q
distribution and basically if you look
at the functional form of it it's simply
an expectation of this these two
quantities the the log of the joint and
log of the surrogate posterior Q. Um
again there's a beautiful proof behind
this as to why it is the case. it it
borrows from Jensen's uh inequality to
to basically build an upper bound on uh
on on surprise which is minus log model
evidence but again we're not going to go
there um it's beyond the scope of this
presentation but we can discuss it later
on. So the idea is that we want to
minimize variation free energy meaning
minimize the difference between the
surrogate posterior and the exact
posterior which is um done by minimizing
this quantity. So the problem is we want
some Q star that minimizes this
variational free energy but the problem
is this objective function is not
available in closed form and the
solution to it is lelass approximation.
It's just beautiful how all these
techniques just join hand together to
pave the way. So what you do is you
literally grab every probability
distribution component in your VF and
you do a second order tailor expansion.
Right? So if you look at the joint, this
is just the definition of second order
tailor expansion, which is um the log of
the joint evaluated at the muse. Um and
then here you've got the second order
term the curvature is over here and then
some some constant terms appear at the
end that we're ignoring here. Um so this
I mean if you do the math you realize
that this is just the log density of a
gausian random variable.
That's what it is. Um you notice that
it's very very similar. This is
literally the exponent of a gausian
distribution. Right? Um but this but
this entire thing is just a log density
of a gausian random variable. Um
so this is the second uh order tailor
expansion of log joint about the point
mu si right.
So if you did that and you did your
tailor expansion for all these
probability distributions inside
you end up with a very nice and
simplified version of the VFE uh which
we denote with a subscript L for LLAS
and it is basically minus log of the
joint plus a bunch of terms that here
here's the beautiful part they're
independent of all these posterior
estimates mus right in other If you want
to find the optimal mu, you're dealing
with this minus log of the joint. So it
simplifies the thing uh the optimization
tremendously. So now approximately
optimal Q found gradient base
optimization can be denoted like this
where we're looking at some posterior mu
si over theta's states and uh lambda
hyperparameters that would minimize this
lelas
approximation of the vf
and if you did that you would minimize
the distance between your surrogate
posterior and the true posterior.
Now
as you know um finding that Q in space
of all possible distributions out there
is no trivial task is actually
completely interactable and that is why
we resort to um the mean field
approximation that basically assumes a
degree of independence between the three
components that we're trying to
estimate. So if you assume that the
three components inside SI are
independent then you're you're saying
that Q factorizes on three components
and three separate distributions over
each component like that which allows us
to estimate each part of the three
components separately. That's the whole
that that's how you make it uh a
tractable search problem. And one other
thing that I wanted to mention is that
um you might wonder okay so we're
talking about log densities in the
definition of the VFE. So why are we
only interested in estimating the
expected value of those log densities
and why are we not talking about uh you
know inferring the coariance matrices of
these u of these um um you know uh uh
basically um yeah of these log gausian
random distributions. Um the answer is
the actual covariance matrices the
posterior coariance under variation loss
becomes an analytic function of the mode
of these mu thi size that we're
estimating. What I'm trying to say is if
you infer these expected posteriors then
you can directly calculate the coariance
uh from those inferred states. So you
don't need to infer the coariances as
well. So the whole problem simplifies to
inferring the posterior expectations and
that's it.
So in online generalized predictive
coding the idea is to infer the xtilda
the theta and lambdas all together in an
online fashion.
So I mean just for your entertainment
this is the final form of the vf.
I mean it looks really I mean really
scary and intimidating. A lot of terms
are here. Uh but I just wanted to point
out that if you break this entire
equation into two components
we have all of this is what we call the
complexity. I mean if you look at all
these little error terms what they're
doing is they're punishing the
divergence of your Q surrogate posterior
from the prior beliefs about those
parameters right but that is called the
complexity which means that uh we want
we're looking for a Q that did not have
to get too far away from the prior uh
distribution that you had about the
parameters.
Right? So the farther it has to go or or
basically the more divergence it needs
to have from the prior it means a more
of a complex surrogate posterior has
been estimated during your optimization.
So we want it to be as simple as
possible in terms of complexity but at
the same time you want it to be as
accurate as possible in predicting your
why your observations.
So um it means that minimizing the VFE
can be accomplished by minimizing the
complexity while maximizing the accuracy
of the predicted sensations.
Right? So you want the least complex and
yet most accurate account for your
observed data. Right?
So after all of those foundational uh
stuff, let's just get into predictive
coding. So we're building our way up to
online generalized predictive coding
here. So it is a generative model,
right, for modeling human perception.
So it is a powerful framework to predict
how the cortex accumulates evidence from
noisy stimuli. It is an application of
the free energy principle FEP. Um um
well the difference between that and
active inference for example is in
active inference you have this component
of action planning and having a model of
the consequences of your actions that
live in the future. But in predictive
coding it is completely passive. It is a
passive sense making of the world. Um
and that's it.
So PC uh or predictive coding focuses on
how the brain can perform probabilistic
inference about the most likely hidden
cause that has caused the sensory signal
and it assumes that the brain has a
generative model of the world through
which it constantly infers three things.
One, it infers the hidden causes that
are that are generating the sensory
data. It learns its parameters theta and
at the same time it estimates its own
uncertainty. This is the lambda
hyperparameters that that I talked about
its own uncertainty about the dynamics
of the world and the observed data.
So model inversion is the term that is
used in the world of the free energy
principle. It happens by minimizing your
variation of free energy. Model
inversion simply means estimating the
posterior. That's what it is. going from
your prior belief about the world into a
posterior belief about the world after
having observed some data
visually. This is what it looks like.
You have a hierarchy
from left to right. We are getting
deeper, right? So you can imagine that
the sensory data comes in from the left
hand side and you have these different
levels. The interesting thing is at
every level of the hierarchy
you have a dedicated generative model
like this. Right? So and as a
consequence of that you have a locally
defined variational free energy at every
level of the hierarchy. Right? So very
nice factorization here happening. Um
and the idea is that during uh your
training
or during your model inversion you want
to estimate all the parameters and or
basic all your post series over all
three components at every level of this
hierarchy. The interesting thing here I
just want to mention before I go into
the all these arrows like what's
happening is that the first layer tries
to make inference about the states of
the world out there by making
predictions about the sensations that
are being received from the world. Then
but what about the second layer? The
second layer makes inferences about some
hidden states inside the first layer
based on the data that is being received
from from the first layer. So based on
the observed data from the first layer
and the third layer does the same with
the second layer. So there there's this
sort of local um uh inference prediction
update sort of uh loop that is happening
between every two pair of consecutive
layers. Um so that so this is the the
one of the main things that is different
from tra traditional deep learning
models. This sort of heian learning
locally factorized sort of um approach
to training your model. So we have two
traffics of information all these arrows
that you're seeing here. We have
top-down predictions that are made about
the sensory stimuli. So every layer
makes predictions about uh about
basically the
the hidden state well the actual layer
below and all the way down until the
first layer makes the prediction about
the actual sensory stimuli. Right? So
top down means from deep to shallow.
Whereas the um and and basically after
that prediction is made some prediction
error will be calculated
um between the predicted sensation and
the actual sensation that has been
received. And then that error is going
to uh basically uh be used to construct
these bottom up prediction error signals
that are weighted by the respective uh
precisions that this is very important.
So the idea is the only thing that will
travel bottom up is that which not could
be predicted accurately. So very nice
sort of efficient uh sort of um
communication scheme here. We're not
going to just uh send everything
everything only the part that was uh
that that was failed to be predicted
accurately.
Um so this sort of uh flow happens
between every two pairs of consecutive
uh layers, right? completely local
and
model inversion after all these bottomup
sign error signals have been pushed
happens and posterior estimates at every
level of the hierarchy for the x's the
thetas and the lambdas at that level get
updated
and then the next data point comes in.
So this happens for every data point
that that comes in from from from over
here. Okay.
Now let's talk about the main
contribution of our work. This two-year
project that we've been dealing with um
online dynamic expectation maximization
or as we call it ODAM is a framework for
implementing online generalized
predictive coding.
So the big picture, right? So here's
your generative model in in generalized
coordinates of motion. The brain
calculates some error terms after making
some predictions. So this just this is
literally the prediction about the
sensation that is subtracted from the
actual generalized um sensations. This
is the prediction about the dynamics of
the world. And these two are basically
looking at the difference between the
posterior expectation and your prior
expectation. So by keeping this error
low, you're trying to say that okay,
don't get too far away from the prior.
Okay. And this is the complexity term
that that I talked about. And the same
story goes between the prior over the
lambda hyperparameters, your uncertainty
hyperparameters and the posterior over
those hyperparameters. This is another
error term. So these four error terms
get calculated
and then your variational free energy
defined under
uh variational LLAS gets calculated and
then during model inversion you do all
of these just classic gradient descent
update on the parameters and your states
of the model. Um, one thing I wanted to
mention was again these are very heavy
topics. Um, and I don't think I'll have
the time to go into the details of this,
but one thing that I just can't resist
to talk about here is um, if you look at
uh, your last equation here, this like
if you ignore this mysterious term,
right? You're saying that I'm going to
update my posterior expectation over the
states using basically my classic
gradient descent approach, right? Um but
this term
is there because of the generalized
coordinates. In plain English, what
you're saying is the rate of change in
my belief about, for example, the
position, the instantaneous rate of
change in my belief about the position.
For me to update that, I'm going to look
at my estimation of the velocity
minus the gradient with respect to
position.
And if I want to update my if I want to
look at the rate of change of my belief
about velocity, I'm going to include my
estimation of the acceleration
during my gradient descent update.
Right? The important thing here is the
the reason we have this term is that if
you note there is no reason for the rate
of change of your belief about say the
position to be equal to your estimation
about the velocity of the world. Why
would they be equal? One is a direct
estimate. The other one is the rate of
change uh of of of your estimate.
The only time that they become equal is
if we've hit the minimum free energy. So
this gradient becomes zero. Right? Um so
that's just one of the beautiful takes
of the generalized coordinates. So this
term if you're coming from machine
learning background just plays as um the
role of the momentum that makes this
gradient descent more educated by the
dynamics of the world. This kappa uh
that we call a lrange multiplier
basically balances the effect of the
gradients and uh the higher temporal
derivative right so how much am I going
to focus on the gradients that I have at
at the moment about my mux versus the
dynamics of the world that I've
estimated.
So this is the general term of
generalized predictive coding. Now we
get into ODAM.
It's an online triple estimation
technique. It has three main steps. The
first is the D step which is just uh the
step of deconvolution as they call it
and it's the step where we infer the
hidden states and their dynamics.
Um this by the way this is uh this can
be looked at intralayer sort of uh
activations neural activation inside
each layer of let's say neurons but
these extas are modeling those dynamics.
If you think about the brain like how
this maps to what's actually happening
in the brain
um the second thing in triple estimation
is learning the parameters of your
generative model that is called the E
step. you want to learn these thetas.
Um, this can be likened to somewhat more
slowly evolving uh things in the brain
such as the synaptic weights. Now the
synaptic weights evolve at a slower rate
than the actual uh neural activities in
the brain that basically resembles a
firework. And the last bit is
uncertainty estimation or the MTEP which
is uh the idea is that I want to or the
model wants to infer the lambda
hyperparameters for that encode
uncertainty in your generalized state
precision matrix and observation uh
precision matrix. So this can be likened
to attention mechanism. This encodes how
much the model would attend towards the
dynamics of the world out there versus
how much it would pay attention to
minimizing its prediction error about
the actual sensory stimuli caused by
those dynamics. Now if that balance is
defective then we have something that
professor callen talks about this is
cineaptopy. That's one of my favorite
words. Um it can result issues such as
hallucination like as a kind of false
inference if you pay for example too
much attention to your um let's say uh
to to your internal states about the
world to the dynamics uh uh um about the
world meaning that just adhere to your
prior beliefs about the world and ignore
the incoming sensory data the incoming
evidence generated by the by by the
world then u you're basically saying,
"Oh, I see my grandmother. I'm talking
to her, but she has passed away for for
the past 10 years." So, you're ignoring
the evidence that there is no one in
front of you. So, the balance between
these two is very important and it's
something that I'm going to show in in
the experiment results as to if that is
defective what the results would be in
terms of inference. So, that is the M
step. So as you notice we have these
three components in triple estimation
that are evolving at different temporal
scales.
The states are being updated really
quickly. The parameters and the
precisions estimates are moving more
slowly. This is what we call the
separation of temporal scales. This is
again one of the things that is missing
from your traditional sort of deep
learning approach of of of training you
know deep learning models. Um
now the pseudo code of ODM is like this
and I know that there are a lot of
mathematical notations here. We can
definitely go through the details of
this uh during the Q&A but I just wanted
to give you an idea of what's happening
during online triple estimation in
online generalized preditive coding. So
we have this observation time series
that we go over. So that at any given
time I grab an observation and I build
the generalized observation vector that
this is basically done by finite
differencing right and then uh let's
just ignore this line. Uh basically what
I'm doing is I'm updating my states
right this line this jacobian is
basically used during the optimization
of my states. um it's based on a local
linearity assumption um that was
proposed by um by Ozaki and um it just
makes a nice balance between gradient
scastic gradient descent and Gaus Newton
optimization a very nice balance between
the two but I digress the idea is that
with that observation y of y subt I'm
immediately updating my states Right?
That is what I mean by fast state
updating. Right? But I'm not going to
update my posterior estimus over the
lambdas and over the thetas. Instead,
I'm accumulating the gradients of my
vation free energy with respect to them
using some uh you know uh classic
exponential smoothing technique. So I'm
not applying them yet. The only time
that I would apply them is
intermittently basically after every uh
I don't know after after a certain
period of uh of having seen some data
for example if um I've seen like let's
say every 256 observations every 128
observations that is what this if
statement is checking every time this
happens then I'm going to apply these
accumulated gradients
and basically update my posterior
estimates over the lambdas and over the
thetas using these accumulated
um these accumulated gradients. And as
you notice the posterior coariance is
going to be directly calculated. We're
not inferring it. This is literally the
inverse of the um the hessen over the
joint distribution. That's what I meant
by the posterior coariance being an
analytical function of the mode.
And one other thing that I do after
doing the E and the M step for parameter
learning and precision estimation um is
that I'm updating my priors. This is
important, right? So you are moving from
your prior belief to to to u to to your
posterior belief. And now the new
posterior belief becomes your prior
belief, your new prior belief for the
next observation to come. And then I'm
just resetting these accumulated
gradients. And one thing I wanted to
note was after every observation has
been seen,
I am updating my states quickly and I'm
very carefully and cautiously and more
slowly updating the lambdas and thetas.
Right? But one thing I'm doing it for
every observation is I am calculating
the free energy given that observation y
subt
and I'm accumulating it into this
variable called free action fa. So what
basically after I've seen the entire
time series I will have accumulated all
of my free energies instantaneous uh in
instantaneously calculated for every
observation. So I end up with a scalar
value. That's my free action accumulated
free energy. And that is what you use to
compare different generative models
together in an online setting. Right? So
the one with the lowest free action is
the model that you would pick because it
has the it has less accumulated
variational free energy compared to the
other model. Right? It means it was
better in balance in basically providing
the least complex and most accurate
account for the data at every time
instance of observing the observations
throughout its lifetime.
Now one other thing I wanted to mention
was a comparison between ODM and the
classic uh DEM algorithm that is being
used um in stocastic DCM dynamic causal
modeling. Those of you who work in
neuroiming
um have definitely heard of DCM and most
likely have worked with it. U dynamic
causal modeling is a generative model.
It's a biohysically interpretable model
of of the brain on in one of the
variations of DCM we have a stochastic
DCM and under the hood it is doing
triple estimation very similar to how
we're doing it but it is offline it's
not online. So as we saw this is my ODM
or our ODM scheme where we have the
observation loop on the most outer side
and you do the dstep or state inference.
You accumulate the gradients for thetas
and lambdas and every once in a while
you you make an M and E step and you
update them and then you compute your
free action and you go to the next
observation. The difference between that
and
is that here it's completely offline. We
have the the parameter learning loop on
the outside and for every step of the E
step you go through the entire
observation loop and for every
observation you do your D step loop
that's the thing everything now is a
loop because it doesn't have to be
online you can keep doing your D step
for that for every observation until
uh the your your inferred states
converge and then you go to the next
observation And basically during that
loop you're accumulating your gradient.
So that part is very similar to how how
we are doing it here. But the main
difference for example this in this part
here is that for every observation we
are doing a lot of these steps and after
con after convergence we accumulate the
gradients of parameters and
hyperparameters. And after we've gone
through all of these observations for
that one E step, we will go through
again an MSTEP loop. Keep updating the
lambdas until we converge and then we
get our free action and then we update
the parameters and go to the next step
of the E step. Right? So if you think
about what's happening, both of these do
triple estimation. The D and E and M
steps both use the generalized
coordinates of motion during the D step.
However, ODM which is our scheme is
online. That means you do not have the
luxury of uh you know doing any
convergence testing.
Why? Because
uh this is modeling human perception,
right? It's an online problem that you
you sample the the data from your world
at at approximately four hertz, right?
So one basically one hertz uh one uh
sample every 250 milliseconds. So it
means once you sample the world do
whatever update you need to do but then
the world is not going to wait for you.
You have to sample the next one this the
next one and the next one. You cannot
keep going through loops and and
basically ignore the incoming data
otherwise you will fall behind from the
world. You will not be able to track the
world and you basically can't live in
the world. Um so the DEM scheme is
offline hence all the convergence
testing.
Um ODM has been implemented uh in
Python. So this is one of the things
that that I'm really happy about because
um we we really want the AI and machine
learning community to get comfortable
with the applications of the free energy
principle. So uh we I'm also a machine
learning guy. Uh we are very interested
in Python and PyTorch and TensorFlow and
all those uh platforms. So the
implementation of OM being in Python and
PyTorch gives uh the our community to be
able to uh you know feel um basically
would make these schemes more attractive
for them to to go towards and basically
play with because we know Python uh but
them has been implemented in MATLAB. So,
Matlab is obviously brilliant uh
environment uh very very good
environment with a lot of tool uh
toolboxes but thing is the machine
learning community nowadays they they
don't usually work with math lab so all
these beautiful and brilliant schemes
that have been implemented and matlab
unfortunately just because they're math
lab uh the machine learning community in
general don't feel like they they don't
feel like the like like going going over
and learning um and basically
understanding them. So hopefully we'll
see the sort of uh flow of researchers
uh to work to develop these schemes also
in Python and PyTorch and other or in
Julia or whatever environment have you
so that everybody can benefit from all
these amazing schemes es especially the
free energy principle which is really
dear to my heart. So now after all of
that, we're going to go towards uh the
experiment setup section.
This is where I'm going to tell you how
in order to actually evaluate our online
generalized predictive coding scheme
ODM, how we set up the experiment, the
generative process, the generative
model, the observations, the priors and
all of that.
So these are the key components,
right?
that we're going to um basically define
the generative process and how the
generative process will cause the
observations and then we're going to
define the generative models. We're
going to define two generative models
actually to compare to be able to
compare uh uh between them as to which
one is better and we're going to define
the priors over the thetas and the
lambda x and lambda y hyperparameters
and there are some tuning parameters
that that we're going to be using and
evaluating over and finally as I said uh
for every generative model after doing
an entire round of online triple
estimation our Only way to compare that
model with some other model uh would be
free action which is our evaluation
metric.
So the generative process that we have
used is a simple generalized lota
system. It's basically a system of
differential equations like this. This
is just the element wise multiplication
and the A matrix is basically um
encoding the relationship the
correlation uh between different like
let's say in this case three different
species let's say of animals that are
interacting like some of them are
killing some some of them some of them
are giving birth some of them are eating
the food of the other one so they have
all these effects on on each other so
this a matrix encodes that relationship
and x is let's say the population of
these uh species.
Um so if you actually encode like put
this a matrix into this equation this is
your generalized alcohol system encoding
the dynamics of three different
population of species
visually on the one on the top is the
solution to this uh to these um
differential equations. So this on the
top has been the way we have plotted
this is be uh is by solving these
equations um by including some state
noise. Right? So this is the inherent
the the true um uh stochasticity over
the external state dynamics that we have
included in solving uh the generative
process equation. So when I say the
generative model wants to infer the
world and its dynamics, I mean it has to
infer these curves. But this is the
invisible world as far as the model is
concerned. And then
we're going to use this to actually
generate observations. And the way we've
done that, we have added elementwise
noise to every one of these um these at
every data point to generate these noisy
observations. So the goal of the
generative model is to rece at any given
time it would receive a
three-dimensional vector of noisy values
and it has to infer a smooth filtered
out clean three-dimensional state
vector.
One thing I need to mention here is that
all the states that we've used here are
smooth like smooth state noise and
smooth observation noise. Um the idea is
that um because we are dealing with
dynamical and basically um like living
organisms um in here the idea is that in
a living organism if you go down like
smaller scales all these seemingly
random and stochast and stochastic sort
of fluctuations they're not
independent of one another in different
time steps. There is a correlation
between them. Um so what I'm trying to
say is that there's a smoothness in
those fluctuations right so because
these models like predictive coding
models um are basically modeling uh the
perception they have to have all these
abilities sight but also the generative
process the world that we're living in
these random uh fluctuations that we are
basically experiencing in our world they
are temporally correlated the a wind
that hits a ship in the sea at every
small intervals of time step those
movements or the gusts of wind all these
uh fluctuations are actually correlated
in time. So that correlation means
there's smoothness. So even when you in
your experiments want to generate these
generative processes make sure that the
stocasticity has a degree of smoothness
and the way you do that is simply just
generate let's say some white noise
random time series and you can just
literally grab a convolutional kernel
let's say let's say a gausian kernel and
just just literally convolve it along
the time series that generates a level
of correlation in some neighborhood and
the entire white noise that you have
then then you have a smooth noise
and sometimes they call it colored noise
but of course there are different
colored noises but that's just a general
term. So now we have the generative
process and we have the generated data.
Now comes the generative model and how
you define priors in that generative
model. Again as a reminder on the bottom
right we have that we have these two
equations like this is what a generative
model looks like right but the
functional form of this f the flow is
what differentiates them in this case so
we are going to be looking at two
different scenarios. Now pay special
attention to this part because this is
going to build the whole is this going
to make the entire experiment um
make more sense. Um we have two
scenarios. In one scenario we have a we
call this scenario different. Why?
Because the Lawrence the generative
model here is a Lawrence system based on
the the the dynamics of a Lawrence
attractor. a chaotic lower and
subtractor whereas the generative
process is a generalized delkavaltera.
So they're different. This means the
internal dynamics of your generative
model is very very different to the
actual world that it's living in. So it
has the wrong impression as to what's
happening out there in the world. Um and
this is basically these are the three
equations of of a Laurens system that we
have. Just a this is just a classic
Lauren system and the row parameter that
we call the raillay parameter that
determines the level of chaoticness of a
luren system that is the parameter that
during triple estimation we're trying to
estimate right we so the the other
parameters we're just going to keep them
fixed and the observation model again
here you see the g function of the
observation model we have kept it as
just an identity mapping which means any
posterior estimate X will be used in
your G function to predict the
observation. So in this case because
it's identity mapping you're looking the
predicted sensation is going to be
exactly equal to the inferred states
right
now in the in the other scenario
scenario same things are different here
we're just saying that okay we have a
GLV generative model we also have a GLV
generative process so this particular
brain model has all the right intuitions
about what's happening in the world so
again it has a classic sort of uh
generalized local tera gener basically
flow function and again we have the
identity mapping in the G function.
So these are the two scenarios and we
want to see how like how a Lawrence
generative model would pair up against a
GLV generative model against one GLV
generative process. It's as if you have
two agents or let's say two entities
that are experiencing a world uh that is
GLV in nature and we see we're going to
look at the living experience of these
two generative models and based on the
free action we can actually compare
them. Um
so the priors that you define for each
one of these generative models as I said
for the Laurens system you're only
looking at the raillay parameter that
you we just define a gausian um prior
over them. And for the GLV uh we have
the interaction matrix. So we here
assume that it's an anti-ymmetric matrix
uh with zeros on the diagonal. This just
ensures that the dynamics from the
perspective of the generative model is
is neverending oscilly dynamics. This is
just to make sure that they will not die
right as time goes by. Um and again we
have defined the priors over the these
elements and because they're
anti-ymmetric like the the values and
below the diagonal are exactly the same
only negated.
So when when because of parameter
learning we're we're looking at
estimating the rows for the Lauren
system and these three values for the
GLD system.
Now what about the precision
hyperparameters? As I said the ratio
between
the prior [clears throat] belief about
the state noise versus observation noise
that ratio matters right. So here we
have kept the expectation the prior
expectation over the noise precision and
the states we've just kept it fixed
right but what we've done here is we
have gone through a grid of values for
the prior expectation over the
observation noise
and this like if you literally divide
uh divide these values by your 500
this constitute the C vector This this
is the prior precision ratio. The C
ratio that encodes attention mechanism
that I mentioned for example one over 50
means the model pays 50 times more
attention towards estimating the
dynamics and nearly ignoring
the the data the incoming data right
that's a very bad balance and one means
equal attention is being paid to the
inferred state and the incoming
observation data and 50 means I'm paying
50 times more attention to my data than
I'm paying to my actual u state
dynamics. Right? So this prior precision
ratio is very very important and we see
uh in in our experimental results as to
how this will affect if it's not tuned
well. And also we here we just looked at
different standard deviations over over
our priors. here. This is just a grid of
values like very tight
standard deviation versus more liberal
standard deviation. That's just a grid
that we've gone over to see which one
does better.
Right? What about the tuning parameters?
Uh, of course, when I'm looking at the
generative model, I can always play with
different things inside. For example, I
can control the orders of motion in the
generalized coordinates when it comes to
these models. For example, I can have a
model that has two orders of motion in
state dynamics, meaning it estimates the
position and velocity, but only one
dimension over the observation, which
which means it's only predicting the
observations themselves versus a model
that has three orders of motion in the
state dynamics, meaning it it's trying
to infer the position, the state, and
sorry, the position, the velocity, and
the acceleration. And it also has access
to the observation and the the velocity
observation of the observations as well.
Right? So this just uh plays with
different orders of generalized
coordinates and sees which one does
better for a given generative model. The
kappa as I said this is the lrange
multiplier and generalized coordinates
of motion GCM. that just balances
um the attention towards whether you're
going to use the gradients mostly for
state for your dstep or whether you're
going to pay more attention to the
higher order temporal derivative in in
your generalized coordinate when you
want to update your posterior estimates
over the states.
This term is just the separation of
temporal scales term that determines for
example every 640 observ uh every six
every um 64 observations which is here.
I'm going to update my lambdas and my
thetas.
The betas are just uh the precision for
getting rate um and the parameter for
getting rate. These are just the
components of my exponential smoothing
that I'm using to accumulate my
gradients and the C is the prior
precision ratio that that I mentioned
like we have all this vector values that
we're going to go through. So for every
pair of generative model and generative
process I'm going to
explore all of these different
combinations
and see for every scenario which one
does better for a given generative
model. So for a Laurens system against a
generative generalized autoter
generative process or for a GLV
generative model again versus the same
generative process I I will go over all
of these combinations.
Now we're going to go uh finally into
the experiment results.
Again
these are the components that we're
estimating. So these are the precision
the posterior estimates over the
precision hyperparameters for the states
and the observations and this is the
post seriousness over the thetas the
parameters of the generative model and
this is literally your uh your states.
Now what you're seeing here is in
scenario same when you have a GLV
generative model and a GLV generative
process
where you're only using two orders of
motion in your generative model. Right?
So the model is only inferring the
position and the states. Sorry, the the
position and the velocity of the states.
Right?
Now the C value as you as you remember
I'm just showing you the effect of what
happens as you increase this C value. In
other words, from paying little
attention to data to paying more
attention to the data to paying all
almost too much attention to the data
and ignoring the dynamics, right? Um
here the solid lines are the inferred
states
and the dashed lines are the true
states. Right. So now we're going to
look at here when the C value is 1 over
50. It means uh it's paying little
attention to the data and paying a lot
more attention to inferring the
dynamics. Remember this is scenario
same. That means the flow of the
dynamics of this generative model is
already a GLV dynamic generalized kabala
dynamic which is identical to the actual
generative process that is also a GLV
system. Right? So you notice with almost
very very little attention to the data
compared to the dynamics already the
inferred states are very close to these
dash line the true generative process
but we want them to be very close right
but that's the beauty of um I mean
that's the important thing I want to
mention here that if your underlying
assumption about the world is correct or
very close to what's actually happening
out there even with such low C value,
you can still manage to to infer
something somewhat acceptable. But you
notice that you're still falling behind,
right? So here the true states is going
up, but it takes the model quite some
time to figure out, oh, it it needs to
go up, right?
And as you increase the C value, see
what happens to the solid line. Are we
going to get closer to the truth or not?
And the answer is yes. As you're paying
more attention to the data, it beca
you're getting closer to the actual
states of of the world. Now, as you
remember, as I just said earlier, um
when it's one over 50, there's this sort
of gap between the truth and uh and
basically the actual the inferred
states. Now the question is is there a
way that I can keep see the same value
but my infer would lag less and the
answer to our uh way we expected to see
it but when it actually happens it's
really cool is if you actually increase
the orders of motion from two to three
meaning now also infer the model infers
the acceleration of the world then what
happens is in the next slide
You notice
with very low um maybe I should actually
let the animation go and I want to pause
when it's one over 50
here. This is the exact C value from the
previous case. But now you see that with
this low value because now you have
three orders of motion. Right? Now you
have a much much better estimation of
the true states of the world. The lag
has disappeared. Right? And you might
wonder why why orders of motion has such
a brilliant effect. If you note
if at any given time your generative
model infers let's say the position, the
velocity and the acceleration and let's
say let's let's just keep it as that.
Mathematically this means that at that
given time your model has the ability to
uh to estimate a sort of local
trajectory into the future of how the
world is going to change, right? And
also a little bit of a memory of what
just happened some time ago. So it's
like by combining temporal derivatives
of your of your posterior estimates at
any given time, the model has this sort
of little trajectory into the near
future and then into the near past. So
it gives it the ability to keep track of
the world better because already it has
a glimpse into the future and that is
why here the gap has disappeared the
second you added the acceleration into
your estimation. Right? And um if you go
to
like basically if if you let this
continue
you notice that there's a downside to
increasing the C value and it's that the
estimations the the inferred states
become so noisy that become absolutely
useless. What's happening here is the
model is paying so much attention to the
data and ignoring the dynamics
50 times more ignoring the dynamics to
the point that the inferred states are
actually the become the the actual
predicted observations.
So it there is no uh state inf like
smooth state inference anymore. The
model is basically just
um inferring basically just just using
the actual observations as the inferred
states. So there is no state inference
um the way we want it to happen. It's
just everything becomes noisy
observations. Right? So this is how you
notice um the value of the importance of
the C value. Right? So so far it's it's
it's interesting. But what happens if we
move to the scenario different where the
Laurens system is up against this
oscilly generative process.
This is very interesting. You notice
that with two orders of motion is
scenario different.
Um
at this C value the system is almost
sleeping. I mean it can barely do
anything in terms of um inferring the
right states. This is nearly useless.
And as you increase the C value,
it begins to take some shape, but at at
its highest value, 50, this is the best
it was able to do, right?
And it's it's it's because it has the
wrong assumption about the world out
there. Laurens generator model assumes a
chaotic world whereas the actual world
is this sort of nice oscilly world the
dash line. Now the question is if we
increase the orders of motion to to
three can it remedy this sort of uh
defect uh in terms of generative model
being so different to the generative
process? Can it help this chaotic
generative model to survive in this
world?
And the answer is yes.
You see at around 10
it has already woken up. Some
estimations are noisy, right? But still
doing a much much better job. And again
if you keep going it gets noisier and
noisier. But the important thing is
let's say at um one or 10
the estimations become much better. And
you already notice by the way at 1 over
50 previously was just almost flat lines
and at one over 50 it already in the
green dimension it's already doing some
some tracking right
and if you increase them if you go to
one like this is a nice balance between
noise noisy states and um and actual
tracking of the true states. It's not
too noisy yet. Um but again obviously if
you keep going it will get a little too
noisy. Right? So the idea is that the
orders of motion come ex become
extremely handy uh when the actual
underlying dynamics of your generative
model is very different to the
generative process.
Now we've talked about the states but
what about
oh sorry let me just also explain
something else here in general the
effect of high orders of motion in
inferring the states now in scenario
different
suppose I have a generative model with
two orders of motion and one for three
orders of motion for a lawren generative
model if I look at the MSE loss between
the inferred states and the true states
at every level of my C ratio,
will I see a meaningful pattern in terms
of this MSE loss being less when I'm
when I'm going from two orders of motion
to three orders of motion? And the
answer seems to be yes because every for
at every C value
if I move from two to three orders of
motion for the scenario different where
I'm always achieving better state
inference the largest jump seems to be
at one when when when I'm paying equal
attention to the dynamics and to the
observations right
and one thing I wanted to mention was
this is very important if you have two
generator models with coming from two
different orders of motion in
generalized coordinates. You can never
you cannot use free action or various
free energy to compare the two models.
Why? Because having high orders of
motion means the model has access to a a
sort of extended data set. Because as
you remember the observations will be uh
turn will turn into generalized
observation internal internally in the
generative model by uh by employing the
finite differencing method to gen to to
basically extend the observations into
generalized observations the velocities
the accelerations of the observations.
So be if the data is different then your
marginal likelihood is different then
your variational free energy is
different. So you cannot compare the two
models like using free energy and that
is why here in order to compare these
models from two orders of motion we have
resorted to the MSE loss between the
inferred states X hat and the true
states X
and in scenario same is also the same
again going from towards motion to three
uh helps with the quality of the
inferred states um importantly um with
what the the the read the true value
happens when the C value is very low. So
this is where the high order of motion
comes to save the day very very clearly.
But when we pass we pass the C value of
one, it has little to none effect. So
you might as well just use two orders of
motion to have a simpler model.
Now what about the precision estimation
the pre the uh the lambdas right the
lambdas over y
um for two order and three orders of
motion here you're looking at boring
graphs right and there's a reason why
they look boring first of all what are
we looking at these are the posterior
estimates over the precision
hyperparameters lambda for two order and
three orders of motion and each color
represents
uh basically different C values meaning
I started to generate the model with
this prior precision ratio and then this
prior precision ratio and let the triple
estimation happen throughout and I
looked at the time series of the
estimated uh precision hyperparameters
you notice that they're nearly flat
and there's a very good reason behind it
is because as you note in the scenario
same and scenario the same scenario um
we have the generative model as a GLV
system which is identical to the
generative process. This means that the
Dstep during state inference is
sufficient to keep free energy low. It
does not need to update the precision
hyperparameters. it remains equally
certain about all the estimates about
the dynamics of the hidden stakes for
example or about the observations of um
um of the the observations that it's
receiving right so it doesn't need to
change your the prior to a very
different kind of posterior and you
notice the shade there's a little shaded
area around them that is shrinking very
very quickly here right that that
basically encodes the uncertainty about
the the posterior estimates over lambda
y. So the message is if the flow of your
generative model is close enough to the
generative process uh the model does not
can handle the tracking uh of the world
only using the mostly mostly using the
dstep.
The same story goes with mu lambda x
again
uh we are dealing with with flat
posteriors not much changes happening.
Um the only thing is like the with um
with three orders of motion if you
compare two and three the reduction in
uncertainty about the estimated lambda
x's is faster.
So three orders of motion helps with uh
you know reducing the uncertainty about
the dynamics uh of the yeah the the
stoasticity of the dynamics.
What about scenario different things
again are different here. So because the
dstep alone is not enough anymore for a
laurens system to keep track of the GLV
generative process it can it's going to
use every two letters disposal to keep
free energy low. So you see that for two
orders of motion and three orders of
motion there is across different C
values especially once you hit uh once
you go beyond one
you notice that there's an initial
change in posterior estimates but
eventually they would flat out which is
actually a very nice observation first
of all the generative model is using the
M step as well as well as a DEP clearly
but also the posterior estimates have
flattened near the end as time goes by
and stabilized. This means that um this
this is some sort of a convergence in
time if you will not inside the OD them
scheme but in time. Um and it's
interesting because the actual as you as
you remember the actual noises that
noises that I've used to generate the
noisy states and the noisy observations
they're actually the precision of those
noises I've kept them fixed. So it makes
sense for the posterior estimates to
converge to some sort of flat or like
fixed and stable uh sort of um
um estimate because it's basically
saying that I believe this is the
estimation and I think it's not changing
so I'm not going to change my posterior
belief about them. Right?
Again for lambda x's is exactly the
same. we have in scenario different the
uncertainty about the state dynamics is
changing initially and then uh they're
stabilizing again because the state
noise that I use in solving my GL
generative process at a fixed precision
right and again you see that the effect
of going from two to three orders of
motion is faster reduction in
uncertainty you see the shaded area uh
shrinks really really quickly compared
to two orders of motion here.
Now what about the parameters?
Again if you remember in scenario same
the parameters were these three items in
the A matrix right for two orders of
motion
we have
we're looking at the posterior estimates
like we have a lot of uncertainty in the
beginning but the uncertainties shrink
as time goes by and you have faster dips
and jumps but eventually as you see they
begin to stabilize
as time goes by and um and if you let
this go for a longer amount of time,
they eventually turn nearly flat. And
and that's again an interesting um sort
of indication because the actual
parameters in my GD generative process
that I use to generate the dynamics and
the generate data, I kept these elements
inside the A matrix and the generative
process constant and fixed. So it again
makes sense for let's say these fast ups
and downs to slowly fade out and
basically converge to um with within a
reasonable range to to to get stabilized
or here you see these big dips but
they're sort of slowing down. That makes
sense for them to stabilize. But this
were two orders of motion right? If you
go to three orders of motion again you
see a similar a similar behavior. Um
again faster reduction in uncertainty uh
more stabilized as time goes by. So it's
again the same behavior.
Um one thing I want to note here just as
a sort of uh important side note the
goal remember is not to recover the
actual parameters that were used in the
generative process.
Remember there is no true model of the
data. So the gener the process that you
use to generate that data is only one
way of explaining that data or those
observations. There are million other
ways billion other ways to generate the
exact same data. So you do not look for
these posterior estimates to get closer
and closer to the actual parameters you
use because there's no ground truth per
se. Right?
What you want is for these estimates to
become uh increasingly more stable as
time goes by because you have used uh
fixed parameters in the generative
process. Now what about the parameter
row in your Laurens system for two
orders of motion? You see like as you as
you change the C value, you get a little
bit of a change for some of the curves
but huge amount of uncertainty around
them.
Right? Again, if you go to three orders
of motion, you have this fast
um reduction in uncertainty for across
all curves and you also have more
movement here. Uh so the model uh for
especially when you go to 10 C value of
10, paying somewhat more attention to
data begins to play around with the
theta estimates over the row more and
more. But eventually I would say the
most important take here is that this uh
this stabilizing aspect of the
parameters also much faster reduction in
uncertainty across all C values uh that
we got from going from two order to
three orders of motion.
Now in terms of future work, we're going
to build a hierarchical model, not just
like the temporal hierarchy that we saw
in generalized coordinates, but actual
spatial hierarchical uh uh online
generalized preditive coding scheme. Um
we're going to introduce the notion of
reormalization. So this is very this is
basically inspired by Carl Fristen's um
um RGM models the reormalization group
generative models basically um actually
no sorry reormalizing generative model
yeah the RGM models um the idea is that
the deeper you go in your hierarchy you
would slow down the dynamics and
basically it it brings out this sort of
gradual coarse straining of the of the
information as you go deeper that that's
renormalization
um sort of aspect that I'm talking about
and the actual interlayer communication
in such models is very very very
different to the classic deep learning
but multi-layer perceptron or
convolutional neural networks it's not
as easy as it is in those models so
there are a lot of things we need to
consider and we're very excited about it
um so a brain inspired method for
dimensionality reduction and
dimensionality. Inflation is something
that we're going to be working on. Um,
again to to be for for we would like for
our model to to be able to deal with
higher dimensional data like it could be
image data, video data or higher
dimensional sort of time series data. So
we need a mechanism to reduce the
dimensionality in to to the dimensions
that my that the model can work with but
also then uh in the other direction to
be able to inflate the dimension to the
input space to so that it can make
predictions about the incoming signal.
But the trick is or the challenge is to
make this a brain inspired scheme
because we want the entire pipeline to
be as inspired by the brain as possible.
Finally, we're interested to see whether
playing with shifts or drifts in the
context in the generative process could
be addressed with our model.
Specifically, uh this is a test for the
effect of generalized coordinates to be
able to very quickly adapt to the to
change in dynamics.
So I would like to again just uh extend
my uh gratitude towards my collaborator
Simon Orbus. Um this was a collaboration
with equal contribution between myself
and Simon and again without his support
this work would not have been possible.
my amazing supervisors uh whose guidance
just kept us from you know uh uh getting
off the right path and you're just you
know getting unnecessarily adventurous
in the in the right wrong direction. So
professor Addio Razi, Professor Brandon
Murphy and Professor Carl Fristen,
we really appreciate their guidance and
supervision. also my amazing colleagues
um from whom I've constant like we've
constantly gotten uh tips and guidance
and invaluable advice uh professor Peter
Peter Seidman from UCL uh Pran Yadv
Lance D Costa and Johan Madrano. So
thank you all very much and also just as
a final slide just would like to
acknowledge um
uh European Union's Horizon 2020
research and innovation program uh under
which this grant was um basically uh
funded. Uh this is a Mary Cury grant uh
and with the agreement number that you
see over there and for those of you who
are interested in reading the preprint
uh you got the preprint under a title
online journalized coding on archive and
we have the code uh publicly available
under GitHub under this link. Um so now
I was thinking of uh also giving a quick
demo of the actual ODM scheme um as to
how you can actually run uh this code.
Um
would would it be okay Daniel or would
you like to do a Q&A first? Yeah, I
think uh let's see some code use and uh
have a little foreshadowing of a more
full tutorial, but just help walk
through the package architecture. What
does it look like to use it? Developer
experience that could be awesome.
>> Yeah, sure. Absolutely. Okay, so uh the
the actual structure looks like this.
You've got the algorithm folder that
holds the Dstep, the Estep and the MSTEP
sort of functions that the ODM scheme
itself here is going to is going to be
using. Um, you have some data utils.
This just helps with reading the data
and the and the basically the not the
data but the experiment setting.
[snorts] Uh, in the example folder I
just have a picture for for people who
want to basically see the what the
result would look like. Um the functions
this is the biggest folder here. Uh you
have folder for generative model like
this is where you can put the dynamics
set dynamics equation in this in this
folder in in this file and your
likelihood uh model which is the G
function and this in this script. Um the
generative processes can be defined
here. So here we just have a glv
generative process. I mean you literally
can just define it the way you want.
Um you can basically look at the way
we've done it. This is going to be very
similar to any other kind of generative
process. You just define your
differential equations and literally
just integrate them.
Um
so I mean uh I mean there are a lot of
stuff here. Um the the the one thing
that I would encourage anybody who's
interested in free energy principle in
general is this folder particularly uh
the actual compute VFE aspect.
uh which shows you how you can calculate
the free energy under var plus
goes over all the details and you notice
some things that you usually don't see
in papers there are mathematical terms
just as a side note like log determinant
of of matrices um you notice that when
you look at the code we have not simply
just taken the log that functionalities
of pietorch to calculate these log
determinants there are a lot of uh sort
statistical tricks that you need to
employ to make sure that these um these
determinants are well behaved and are
not numerically unstable.
So as you look at the code you realize
that uh that things are for example here
of compute log debt this if you open
this function you realize there are a
lot of checks to make sure that um the
numerical instability would be
minimized.
Um
so
basically that's about the the most the
the the bas the basic structure of the
repository. Now in the parameters YAML
file I need to make it look nicer a
little bit later on. Uh I just want to
maybe I can just run the experiment
because this is going to take a long
time. And while that is running in the
background I'm just going to explain
what we're looking at in the YAML file.
This is where you're going to configure
your um your experiment. Let me just run
this.
So what's happening here when I run this
a your generator model here is a
lawrence system is built with a prior
over the over the row parameter. This is
a prior expectation. This is the
standard deviation around it. So if you
have a different generative model that
has let's say three parameters. Let's
say you have here a generative loka a
generalized loca volta generative model.
This is how you can actually define the
prior expectation over the three
parameters and you know standard
deviations around your three parameters.
The reason this is a list of lists is
because you might want to uh check
different uh combinations of these uh
priors right like a grid of prior that
you might want to explore. So you can
add another list of three values here to
check for another combination of prior
over those parameters. So you also have
parameters over your lambdas. So we have
define again the expected uh value and
the standard deviation.
You notice that these priors are that
these ones are a little tricky. You
definitely need to look at the paper to
see how you how we go from the precision
space to uh to to the lambda space and
vice versa. This is this this is beyond
the scope of you know just explaining uh
in in this short period of time. you
need to look at the the actual paper and
see the mathematical trick that is used
to to com to basically convert these
precisions um these priors from the
precision space to the lambda space.
Um the optimizer this just basically
encodes that okay when you update the
posterior coariances um you would uh you
you would carry your posterior
coariances as time goes by. So you would
update your prior coariance to the
posterior coariance as well. Sometimes
you might not want to carry them just to
keep the model open-minded about the
world as it as it experiences. Otherwise
if you do carry you notice that the
shaded area that I showed in experiment
results, they would just shrink as time
goes by. Right?
Um the Ozaki scheme is what I mentioned
about uh I mean you need to I I I just
recommend uh your viewers to look at the
paper to look at the the details of the
Ozaki scheme. The kappa this is just a
lrange multiplier that we talked about.
Uh again during lambda and theta sort of
update this is where you determine um
how the gradients regarding the lambda
and theta can be applied.
And this basically shows the separation
of temporal scale. So every 128
observations you can apply the gradients
over the thetas and the lambdas. These
betas are just uh you know the
exponential smoothing factors.
Excuse me.
This is the generative process
where you define the noises uh the noise
of the of the uh the the features of the
white noise and how the the the gausian
kernel that you're going to use to make
it smooth. The name of the generative
process is a GLV or the sampling rate
when you want to solve uh the system uh
or basically the step size not the
sampling rate the step size that you're
going to use to actually um uh you know
solve the system of differential
equations of your GLV um and the time
like how long you're going to do that.
So for example here it means 100 divided
by 0.1 it means you're going to generate
1,000
uh samples right
so you would sol so this just solves
them uh so this just creates the
trajectories of external states in your
GLV generator process while including
this smooth noise on top of it and then
um eventually uh as as you see down
below you can define the observ ation
smooth noise and this noise will be
added on top of the previous um the the
generated state noises to to actually
construct the noisy observations that
are going to be fed into your generative
model. Um and here you're just defining
your generative model. You can say the
dynamics is a Lauren system. The
likelihood is mapping just identity
mapping. Um this is basically the f
function and the g function your
generative model. This is important.
This is basically looking at the orders
of motion and generalized coordinates
along x and y dimensions. Um for this
implementation you you always have to
make sure that uh your states has one
order of motion higher than the
observations.
Um and that's it. So this is basically
the the structure. Um so when you run
the code
this is what you see like you basically
see this um evolution of
so 1,00 data points right so so every
every 10 observations the code uh
outputs a variational free energy and
accumulated variational free energy
which is your free action right and once
it is done
it goes to the next round so remember
that you can define a grid of experiment
hyperparameters that the model the the
code would just go over the entire grid
and save a lot of results for every
combination of your experiment
parameters. So if I just stop this and
show you the output of what you would
receive.
Um
so this is the folder that is generated.
Um you see a lot of NA GNA sort of like
sort of messages here. It's because this
code has the ability to run both on a uh
you know cluster that that that is
managed by let's say a manager like
slurm. So you can run this code on on a
slurm sort of cloud um and and it can
just run smoothly no problem. And and
here these values here that are are na
is because I'm running the code now on
my local machine. that there are things
like job ID, task ID that are only
encoded or basically useful when you're
running your code on slurm. But here
they're just uh we don't need them. So
that's why you see this NA values the
date and time. And here this is your
free action. The first value that you
see the last value is the MSE loss
between the inferred states and the true
states.
Um if you go inside
you have basically everything that you
need in ter all saved as a as numpy uh
sort of arrays. For example, you have
you remember I mentioned free energy is
complexity minus accuracy. You have the
accuracy of your model throughout the
triple estimation. The complexity
component of free energy. You have the
actual free energy which is the
combination of the two. You have uh the
covariance posterior coariance over
lambda x lambda y over your parameters.
You have the generalized predictions. Um
also the generalized sensations. This is
the y tilda.
You have the generalized state
estimates. This is mux, mux dot, mux dot
and so on. Um you have the lambda x and
lambda y posteriors posterior estimates.
have the priors over them over the
thetas. For example, that that um this
is basically the ATA is the expectation
of that prior and pi is the precision
over that prior over those thetas
and I mean so on and so forth. You have
all the data related to noise values
that you have you have selected the
actual observations Y. So this is the
colored noise that was generated to uh
to be actually added to your to your
wise. Um this is I mean basically what
I'm trying to say you have everything
that you need to to generate plots from.
So this folder is just a plus that the
code generates automatically.
Um so for example it generates let's say
let's look at Y hat for let's say Xhat
but Xhat is just the inferred states and
um if you look at it um for example it
just looks at the inferred states along
three dimensions here um it it just the
the plotting just uses all the results
that that we have saved uh in numpy
format here and Um maybe I should also
show you here in plotting this is
uh so this these are all the plotting
sort of functionalities that are that
are being used. Uh of course you can you
can tweak them you can change them the
way the way you want but I would say the
most important thing um is
is all of these saved values. Also in
the combo here you you just have all the
combinations of the experiments
parameters in your YAML that are saved
here in case for your future reference
if you want to if you want to take a
look at the snapshot is literally a
snapshot of your ramp of your YAML file
literally right so you might later on if
you have 1,000 folders here you might
want to look at a subset of them that
has only three orders of motion for
example you can make the search using
those snapshots
And um I would say that is it Daniel.
Amazing. Very cool. I I I'll just ask
one
burning question, but there's so much to
to learn and and and try. So you said
that variational free energy cannot be
directly compared across the models with
different generalized orders.
>> Yeah. However, within an order, are the
VFS sometimes or always comparable? And
then if we do want to compare across
orders, do we use base factor or model
selection or h how do you actually pick
the [snorts] right model like for a
given data set?
Yeah. So, um within an order of motion,
you definitely can always use variation
free energy to compare the models.
That's definitely the case. The reason
is because if you remember um various
free energy is just a proxy for model
evidence and model evidence is
probability over your observations. So
if the observations the data is the same
between two models then the proxy for
model evidence can be used to compare
different models. Um the second model
has higher orders of motion. It means it
internally has extended the data to
higher temporal derivatives, higher
temporal estimations. So not only does
it have y which is the same time series
that the other model might have but it
also has let's say use finite
differencing to estimate the velocities
of how these observations are changing
in time. So now it has the marginal
likelihood is over an extended set of
observations. So then by by extension
variational free energy will be over a
different kind of data set. So you
cannot compare them and if you want to
compare it and that was a problem that I
struggled with with for quite some time
and for me
[clears throat] what uh what I thought
would basically make sense which is
basically wrapped up in this slide is
when I want to let's say ask which model
did better in terms of like like I have
a model with two orders of motion and
one with three orders of motion.
I basically thought maybe this is the
way to do it. I'm not sure if this is
the only way to do it. Um but I thought
okay the ultimate goal of my the whole
online generalized predictive coding is
to do better inference about the world.
So why not just compare the inferred
states versus the true states,
right? And that is how the MSE loss
between the two
uh the the two models uh was what I used
to compare the quality of inference as a
proxy to basically compare models from
you know coming from different orders of
motion. But again
uh we cannot use free action or
variation of free energy to compare
these models coming from two orders of
motion.
So is there any other
model fitting or how or is it's a very
austere model right whether it's a
financial time series or some biometric
or something that makes it sound like
there's no other we don't need to
have other features of like a world
model or some domain knowledge because
we're basically just pointing it to the
generalized coordinates. So like have
you found across different data sets
that that captures well in comparison
with alternative time series methods or
h how or do you incorporate like domain
specific knowledge?
>> That's a very good question. Um you see
like the reason this work took nearly
two years was because this has not been
done before. So we had to basically
build uh the foundation for online
generalized predictive coding and this
we didn't know if it was going to work
basically we didn't. So now we know that
it works and these are all synthetic
data and that is why for example the
future work section I said we we need
dimensionality reduction and
dimensionality inflation techniques so
that we can use uh a variety of data
sets of variety of dimensionalities and
to address the other question that you
asked which is really important to be
able to benchmark this against other
online schemes either machine learning
methods or simple statistical methods
um to see whether like what's the value
that this would bring to the table. Uh
but yeah, that is definitely in our
future work a proper benchmark. Yeah.
>> Cool. Well, do you want to maybe mention
any last thoughts and point people to ML
Dawn and everything to to stay tuned?
>> Um I just want to first of all um again
thank you for the opportunity. It's
always a pleasure to be presenting at
active inference institute and um I just
wanted to um really just I would say
yeah just just one final thought uh that
has been in my mind for a very long time
is that for any of you out there who are
interested in the free energy principle
um please make sure that you would start
from the fundamentals
It will take time. Yes, it's not easy.
Yes, definitely. But once you do that,
once you go to the nitty-gritty details
of uh you know statistical details and
all of that, believe me, it it will take
time. But once you found like understood
them then you'll have the ability to
make all sorts of alterations and uh and
changes in the models that you're
creating because you understand the
underlying bricks as to you you you'll
be in full control of what you're going
to do. You will not just be using
someone else's package. You can make all
sorts of changes you want in that
package or build your own package from
scratch. It is only then and only then
that you can claim that you have
understood this the free energy
principle active inference predictive
coding and all of these models. Please
do not forget the fundamentals. That's
my final thought on this.
Amazing. Very well said. If only there
were a textbook by that name
fundamentals
which we could study and learn from.
Uh well I I mean uh recently I think uh
Sanjief has uh successfully published
his active imperence book that is just I
suppose I haven't had the pleasure to
read it. It is on my list but I think
that is the the book uh to actually help
people who actually want to build these
things to really understand what they're
doing. So hopefully there'll be more and
more um strong willed people like Sanjie
to to try to make things easier and u
basically um more tangible for people to
get into specifically like coming from a
machine learning background myself took
me nearly a year maybe even more to
actually understand what's happening in
the world of the free energy principle.
Um, so I can completely understand h why
the machine learning community might
might feel a little discouraged when
they look at the free energy principle,
the papers out there because the math is
really intimidating. It's still
intimidating to me when I look at it.
Uh, but but believe me, once you get the
fundamentals right, it all begins to
make sense. It's just so beautiful. I
just hope that the machine learning and
AI community would give this a chance
and would go towards it and try to
really advance this area. That's what we
all we all are trying to do. So
hopefully one day uh it will be more and
more more popular than today and more um
used than today.
>> Wonderful. The epistemic value is like
wine. The pragmatic value is like honey.
>> Oh my. That's that's beautiful.
[laughter] Who said that? Is it yours?
>> Just thought of how sweet it is to know
and to to try and to learn.
>> That's beautiful. Very very beautifully
said.
>> Thanks a lot, Daniel. Really appreciate
it. And thanks to everyone who listened.
Really appreciate.
>> Cool. See you next time. Bye
>> bye now.